tax season is here as the world marks
one year of a global pandemic
for many it was a year of unprecedented
disruption
in our personal and economic lives taxes
are
in many ways a reflection of the real
world and the real economy so
the real world and the real economy were
a total mess in 2020 and so the tax
season that we're having right now
reflects that the u.s government
responds to the pandemic
and changes in your own life could
combine to make this a potentially
tricky year for taxes
here's what you need to know congress
approved two rounds of stimulus payments
in 2020
individuals earning less than 75 000 and
couples earning less than 150
000 were eligible for the full amount
taken together adults at these income
levels were eligible for eighteen
hundred dollars from the government
plus an additional eleven hundred
dollars for every child under 17.
many people quickly received the full
amount that they were entitled to
but others didn't the irs has the
information it has that you've sent
them before right so when they decide
how much to send you and
they're looking at okay what's your
income and what's your family size
they're gonna just pull from the
information they had so in march of 2020
they were pulling from
2018 returns in 2019 returned
if your income went down in 2020 from
being ineligible or partly ineligible to
fully eligible
then you can use your 2020 tax return to
claim
the rest of that money let's take an
extreme case of
an individual who made 150
000 in 2019 and so they didn't get the
1200 payment they didn't get the
600 payment because all the irs knew is
oh this is someone who made 150 000
if that person then in 2020 made 50 000
and would have qualified for the
full payments then you can go ahead and
claim that full 1800
on your 2020 tax return and there's also
circumstances
where your household might have changed
so the most common case would be you had
a baby during 2020
the irs would have no way to know about
that until you until you send in your
2020 tax return
and so you'll be able on that to claim
500
from the first round and 600 for the
second round but what if you're one of
the lucky ones that had a good 2020.
don't worry you can get more stimulus
money if you're owed it
but the irs won't take any stimulus back
so let's take an example of someone who
made 50 000 in 2019 they got a full 1200
check in march a full 600 check in
december so that's 1800
based on the income that they had to
qualify within that range
and then you had a good 2020. you were
one of the lucky ones and say you made
as an individual 120 000 you wouldn't
have qualified for any money
that's okay these payments are not
taxable no matter what the circumstances
are that have changed
if you're owed more stimulus money you
can claim it on line 30 on your tax
return
there's also now a third round of
stimulus payments that congress passed
in march
these aren't relevant to your 2020 taxes
but filing your 2020 taxes will update
the information the irs has
so it could help you get the full amount
you're entitled to sooner
the pandemic closed offices this year so
many workers set up home offices or
relocated for more space
the irs from the federal perspective if
you're working in
maryland or virginia or new york or new
jersey it doesn't matter to them the
federal income is the same
but it can have significant state tax
consequences
some states like new york are known for
being particularly
aggressive in enforcing their state tax
laws and trying to
expand the boundaries of the work that
they're taxing
other states may not be in general if
you ended up spending the year
working in a state where you live as
opposed to the one that you used to
commute to it's worth taking some time
to figure out
how that state pairing works together
millions of people lost their jobs as a
result of the pandemic in 2020 and
congress funneled assistance to many
out-of-work people
through state unemployment systems many
first-time recipients were surprised to
learn that unemployment benefits are
taxable income
and that they might be facing a large
tax bill if they didn't have enough tax
money withheld from their unemployment
benefits
but in the law passed in march 2021
congress moved to prevent these surprise
tax bills
what congress did in march retroactively
said
the first 10 200 of unemployment
benefits
per worker are exempt from taxes
for households making up to a hundred
and fifty thousand dollars
took away that surprise tax burden for a
lot of people it's they gonna save about
25 billion dollars to those households
since this long they passed recently
some recipients have already paid taxes
on the first 10
200 of their unemployment benefits for
2020
either through withholding or filing
early if you're one of those people
don't worry if you filed your tax return
and then basically paid taxes on your
unemployment benefits
the irs says don't do anything don't
send in an amended return
they're gonna do the math themselves and
send out
refunds to people who are in that
situation
thankfully the irs has given taxpayers a
little more time to figure out their
taxes from this strange and difficult
year
the filing deadline this year we're all
used to
april 15th being april 15th but this
year it's not
for most people the deadline to pay your
2020 taxes
is may 17th now not april 15th
if you're in texas oklahoma or louisiana
because of the storms
all the deadlines are pushed to june
15th
you